jets de projectiles du côté des
manifestants lancer de gaz lacrymogènes
et de balles en caoutchouc
du côté des forces armées depuis
plusieurs jours la révolte populaire
pour réclamer un changement radical au
liban a repris malgré le confinement
les protestataires sont descendus dans
les rues endommageant la façade d'une
banque dans le centre de tripoli
la deuxième ville la plus importante du
pays vingt manifestants ont été blessés
dans les affrontements nocturnes dont 4
hospitalisé la veille
ces violents heurts ont été marquées par
la mort d'un manifestant de 26 ans tuée
par balles par les forces de sécurité
les politiciens ou le sens de cet homme
sur les mains fawaz al saman était un
gars adorable qui aimait son pays et sa
patrie il meurt comme ça pour rien parce
qu'il réclamait ses droits les plus
élémentaires
nous le répétons nous voulons un système
judiciaire impartiale et des élections
anticipées afin de pouvoir éliminer ces
voleurs qui pillent le pays
l'autre chose que nous voulons dire est
un message aux dirigeants de l'armée les
personnes affamées ne sont pas censés
être la cible des balles ces gens sont
descendus dans la rue pour demander à
avoir assez à manger ils ne tiennent ni
fusil ni artillerie et sont venus dure
aux hommes politiques qui les ont
laissés affamés vous avez pris notre
argent vous avez endetté le pays de 100
milliards et vous n'avez rien fait pour
le pays
ils sont assis volée oblige les gens à
mendier sur le pas de leur porte à
beyrouth c'est une centaine de
manifestants qui ont défilé dans les
rues de la capitale
ils se sont réunis dans le quartier
hamra où se trouvent la banque centrale
du pays les banques l'un des symboles de
cette contestation populaire les
libanais se disent inquiets et en colère
le dollar vaut maintenant 4000 livres
libanaises 4200 livre jeunesse pour un
dollar
tout est devenu cher la nourriture est
devenue plus chère tous les prix ont
augmenté pour être honnête si on n'a
rien on ne peut même pas acheter de la
nourriture ou du pain on n'a pas les
moyens d'acheter quoi que ce soit
confronté à sa pire crise économique
depuis la guerre civile
le liban s'est retrouvée en défaut de
paiement avec une dette publique
s'élevant à 92 milliards de dollars 45 %
de la population vit désormais sous le
seuil de pauvreté